so this quadrant here what you guys want
to hear a rap about Lou Ferrigno's left
testicle I love it and I always thought
with pronounced Ferrini oh so thank you
for correcting me I like that that's the
very American Way isn't it your surname
sounds vaguely ethnic will pronounce it
our way thank you you love correcting
accents I was in an Italian restaurant
and I ordered a tomato salad with basil
and oregano and he just looked to me
going you have ruined all those words
Lou Ferrigno's left testicle I like it
is that specifically does he only have
one testicle or is that the one that
shows more in his shorts just the one
that's lower
are you his personal physician used to
be okay and then I divulged his personal
measurements in public and now I am no
longer so Lou Ferrigno's left testicle
just gonna go out and say there that's
pretty close to 9th century crop
rotation my favorite ones of all time
middle of the middle what do you guys go
what was you what can you say that Green
Acres and the second word was Arnold the
pig okay so who is Green Acres Armond
Arnold
it was a show back in the 70s very
carefully trying to hide your age there
you like what the 70s I don't know I
wasn't alive classy classy that's
exactly that's that a lot of you'll
behave like that so green excellent show
like a soap opera or what kind of show a
comedy and there was a pig called Arnold
your your you're describing it by using
words I still don't know it was a hair
above hee haw what cut these guys off it
had too much
whatever it is Green Acres Arnold Lou
Ferrigno's left testicle what you you
guys over here what you want to rap
about enemas and black hole I will
combine those quite fittingly a black
hole enema Lou Ferrigno's left testicle
Green Acres Arnold let's get word from
the back of the room surfboard showers
[Applause]
I think your cult came to the comedy
show tonight brilliant let's take one
final one this can come from anywhere in
the room just make it a good one
MK ULTRA do you suggest it - now there
haven't you so yeah no that's alright
come back tomorrow night and suggest
that because that is it good that's a
good one I like it
give us one else ago well yeah you took
too long for that so what happened was
you said space you said nurses playing
cards used to the final frontier
we'll take nurses playing cards the
final frontiers nurses playing cards the
final frontier black hole enemas Lou
Ferrigno's left testicle surfboard
showers and Green Acres Arnold you don't
need to cheer every time I say surfboard
showers they got me this lovely people
of her most of each comedy magic club to
close out the night is a little thing
called a freestyle that's a rap made up
on this quad based entirely on those
suggestions let's drop that B let's get
this going
I'm glad that you guys into it as well
that's pretty cool yeah I've got a
clogged intestine let me tell you my
goal cleaner out gravitational pull like
a black hole I'll be walking to my
doctor right a my cats down bend on the
table the water turns brown when it's
flowing now the true pierre is forward
from me looking up into space and trying
to spy what I see I get a picture get a
telescope light through a prism stitch
the images together with a mad algorithm
made by a girl saw that stuff on social
media reply whole animal would make the
process be media reports it out yeah
with such force it runs away like a
galloping racehorse Arnold was a pic
though not a fine filly I've never seen
the show so it might sound silly I was
like can you explain and set me straight
there can you tell me what's the deal
with Green Acres you tried to subtly
differ
you were like well it's TV not the stage
just a little hair above a hee-haw I was
like you're off your rocker like a
seesaw we saw that show on the TV then
Arnold was a pig he's my little pink
friend
I'm never gonna be you know not Chris
why well it doesn't matter because I'm
not Jewish but no mistake then I reject
the bacon Arnold is a nice Pig you're
mistaken for babe frequently that's the
pig in the sea he's an older pig so
probably less break on the teats then
he's a lady with the t's go into the BG
air side of the sea of the coast opposed
to keep my pets so clean no sand on
there were no sunscreen why because I
like to lacquer in the shower I stay in
there for 60 minutes called us up an
hour oh why do I do it's my only reward
when I rip that curl on my big surfboard
a surfboard
won't believe the power the words I've
got other people just flower and stare
with me and say we need to learn we've
never even heard some borscht our turn
no one even cares about that y'all I'm
gonna move over here here
I was adoring the collaboration one step
beyond the final frontier but this is a
win one yeah in the back of my garden
there's a yard there are four great
nurses they're all playing cards sit in
there yeah I serve them a dish and one
by one they'll say go fish
it passes round there to the next place
in the game I know the nurses all by
name Brian Kevin Joseph and Steve yeah
they were all guys got the trick up my
sleeve people define the system lay
these doctors as males now that
stereotyping fails like a pair of shorts
when you get so angry lou ferrigno yeah
he wouldn't understand me that guy was
the Incredible Hulk he was famed for
green flesh and incredible bulk mass
pets bad biceps and big gluts do but
what is over there but I ask you which
hanging down there
so solo testicle mr. fine fellow and
knock him is green chess please and say
Lou look at that left teste it's a twin
like a brother I give it just a weight
and I say let's discover I'm gonna hold
it up before you kick off Lou just kind
of grip this stuff and then do a cuff
there you go
[Applause]